[Music]
protests are still ongoing in louisville
kentucky after the grand jury verdict in
the brianna taylor case last month
back in march briana taylor's boyfriend
opened fire on police after they
announced a search warrant at night and
entered her apartment
the grand jury indicted one officer in
that the indictment accused him of
endangering
others for returning fire a police
officer had been shot when he did that
after that verdict came down a blm
sympathizer apparently shot two police
officers in louisville
one of those officers major aubry
gregory called for calm on wednesday
saying quote hate and violence
progresses nothing
that's demonstrably true but blm's
leaders
and the news media apparently disagree
with that message they've decided to
claim that the attorney general of
kentucky
daniel cameron has somehow betrayed
the black community kind of a shocking
accusation but they said it
attorney general is about to respond on
this show in just a moment but first
hear what those attacks against him look
like
don't look at the fact that this guy is
black that does not mean anything he is
a republican through and through he
spoke at the rnc he told you who he was
believe him
at least he's skin folk but he is not
kin folk and so just like he thinks they
can't speak for kentucky
because he's up there with a black face
he does not speak for all of us i think
what i saw this morning was
a bull connor speech in 2020
and you're right unfortunately it was
being given by a black
prosecutor i'm so disgusted by this i'm
so disgusted by daniel cameron's
performance
i am so sick and tired of black people
going on the air
and performing for violence and white
supremacy and state-sponsored violence
against black people
and claiming their mamas and claiming
they're because of black men they care
about it
those attacks are so cruel and so
vicious
and unfair that we hesitated to air them
again and we didn't
want to play them right before
introducing the attorney general of
kentucky daniel cameron
but he asked us to because he wants to
respond of course he saw them as well
we're happy to have mine tonight mr
general thanks so much for joining us
again it's i'm embarrassed even to play
that
before this interview but i have to ask
you
what did you think when you saw that
well look
uh tucker it is so unfortunate uh
that because i have a different
political
philosophy and because in my role as the
attorney general and as the special
prosecutor
in the brianna taylor investigation
because i led
with the facts and the truth and had
that lead to the conclusion
somehow i've betrayed my race it is
repugnant
it is so disappointing but it's par for
the course
anytime someone stands for the truth and
when that truth
is different from a narrative that has
been pushed
by others this is how they respond
and if you look at my social media
you'll see countless folks
who have made similar statements and
comments but i'm here tonight to say
that enough is enough
and that black republicans folks that
believe in the truth
that we're going to stand up and that's
what i did
in presenting all of the information to
the grand jury
in the brianna taylor investigation
that's what i'm charged to do that is my
responsibility
as the attorney general of the
commonwealth of kentucky that's what the
citizens here of all 120 counties
deserve
uh and that's what they elected me to do
well god bless you for your calm and for
your bravery i don't think i could i
don't think i could handle it if i were
you
but i'm glad that you can so if you
since you're here
um and we've covered this case quite a
bit there's been a lot of
competing stories about what actually
happened clear up for us if you would
since you're no one was more intimately
involved in this than you
what misinformation is out there about
the briana taylor case
well the biggest myth that is being
promoted right now
is the idea that sergeant mattingly one
of the officers who was
administering the search warrant in the
morning hours that brianna taylor's
apartment was shot by friendly fire
meaning shot by another
officer look i've taken to calling this
a conspiracy theory
in order to believe this narrative
that's being promoted by a defense
attorney in louisville kentucky
you have to believe one to defy physics
and disregard the trajectory analysis
but you have to believe that the officer
that was standing outside of the
apartment
shooting into the apartment that he had
a magic bullet
and that that bullet uh go went through
the apartment unit
and then made a sharp turn left without
any obstruction or any impediment
to match it up with the entry point of
the wound
that sergeant mattingly suffered it is a
silly notion
it's one of the biggest myths that has
been promoted
here in the last few weeks before three
weeks ago and before this defense
attorney
uttered this statement it was a foregone
conclusion
that what happened that evening was that
kenny walker
brianna taylor's boyfriend friend fired
a shot
at the officers the officers
responded and returned fire justified in
doing so because they had been fired
upon
and the tragedy and again i've said this
from the very beginning the tragedy here
is that brianna taylor was in that
hallway as well and was hit yes
but the tragedy doesn't allow for me to
not
present the facts and the truth and
that's what we've done here
amen and that's as an outsider that was
exactly my read on it it looked like a
tragedy
everyone is sad that she died um but it
doesn't
seem like it justifies violence in the
streets you said that as well you said
it's not justice
for the mob to commit violence and you
were attacked for saying that what do
you make of the response
well again there were a lot of people
inside
and outside a lot of celebrities a lot
of folks that
were either misrepresented the facts
because it was to their advantage
or didn't know all the information they
made conclusions first
and then want to cherry pick the facts
to meet those conclusions
i don't have that luxury as the attorney
general here in the commonwealth
my responsibility is to the truth and to
the information
and then that is ultimately what leads
to the conclusion
we presented all of the information to
the grand jury uh
ultimately we presented to them as well
the fact that they the officers
mattingly and cosgrove were fired upon
and they were justified
in returning their fire we've obviously
have a prosecution
into a third officer that was there that
night i can't get into the specifics
because that is an ongoing prosecution
but again a lot of folks had already
made up their mind
and weren't interested in what the truth
is and now are still trying to
cherry-pick
so that they can fashion a narrative
that meets their agenda
and advances their own interests
man i hope someday we can have dinner
and i'm going to ask you what you think
of the many other prosecutors who bowed
to political pressure but i'm not going
to ask you that on tv because
i could be putting you in a bad spot in
the meantime i i'm going to take you up
on that dinner
i hope so daniel cameron attorney
general of
the commonwealth of kentucky thanks so
much